dear madam president was a la fonda lion
do Salaam we are just at the beginning
of a new decisive decade for Europe I'm
convinced
Madam President said you will clearly
defined strategy and recently leadership
will benefit the Commission and the
future of your superiorities that you
have set for the European Union are
consequential Europe has the potential
to provide global leadership to on such
challenges we need to address urgently
climate change so forth Industrial
Revolution inclusive digitalization
gross competitiveness as well as
Europe's role in the world I deeply
believe that reconciling our planet and
our economy with the goal of achieving
the first climate neutral continent will
serve and has to serve as a global role
model for sustainable capitalism I look
forward to witnessing transformational
journey under your leadership Madam
President
we welcome you very cordially
not the first time here in Davos but
because you surfed also in the world of
the World Economic Forum but the first
time as the president of the European
Commission
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen excellencies dear
Klaus thank you very much it's wonderful
to be back here
indeed the World Economic Forum stands
for multilateralism for global
cooperation for listening to each other
for not new ideas for the future
and I'm very well aware that some say
that the global order as we've built
together last 50 years is outdated and
whether we agree or not we all have to
recognize that it has been challenged
every day and this is not a question of
only one country or one party or one
president it is a global phenomenon
driven by personal sentiments people
feel that their workplace is changing
before their eyes they are worried about
the future of their business or the
future of their families they stick to
all the rules they give their very best
every day but no matter how hard they
try they feel the world is moving faster
and well there are different ways to
deal with these obvious changes you can
either move forward at the exclusion of
others like restricting the internet
fuelling nationalism building on a
narrative as furthest zebb them or you
can take an inclusive approach cooperate
with your neighbors bring to the table
all the scientists from all over the
world connect your business and your
innovators to create new markets and
sustainable jobs and those are the
answers
people are asking for they are ready to
change but they want to see that they
can make a decent living and to find
these solutions among nations I think we
need to upgrade and modernize our
international forum and we need
leadership to take these topics to the
next level there is no better example
for this than climate change it is a
global challenge most of us not all of
us but most of us agree that we need to
act we feel the urgency I mean the
evidence is overwhelming if you look at
the droughts the floods the fires the
heat waves the rising ocean the extreme
weather situations we've had before but
not as frequent but not as intense as it
is today the World Economic Forum's
so-called Global Risk report identifies
that the top five risks for our economy
are all climate related there is still
scope to address these risks but the
window of opportunity is rapidly closing
we have to act now
and this is the reason why the European
Commission presented as its first
priority the European Green Deal Europe
will be the world's first climate
neutral continent by 2050 and it will do
whatever it takes to unlock the
investment the innovation and the
creativity that is needed over the next
decade
the European budget will mobilize one
trillion euro of investment it's gonna
be European money national co-financing
private investment this is you who we
need to join and of course strongly
supported by the European Investment
Bank this is our climate bank and this
will create a green investment wave and
there is a demand for it last month 44
of Europe's largest investors
representing six trillion euro of assets
called on the European Union to put
climate neutrality into law they want
that law they say they need that law
because it will give them the confidence
the accountability and the reliability
to make long-term investments the
European Green Deal is our new growth
strategy the novelty and the difference
to our fossil fuel based model is that
we will foster growth that is not
extracting resources but that gives back
to the planet more than it takes away
from it and Europe has the first mover
advantage and wills will strengthen it I
think the whole world increasingly needs
clean technologies and new solutions
because we will all face the same limits
of fossil fuel based growth and
therefore Europe will seize the
opportunity our battery alliance smart
grids green hydrogen power offshore wind
power clean steel decarbonize gas you
name it
this will create innovation it will
create value and it will create jobs but
there is no point in only reducing
greenhouse gas emissions at
home if we increase the import of co2
from abroad and this is not only a
climate issue it's also climate issue
but it's not only a climate issue it is
also an issue of fairness it is a matter
of fairness towards our business of
fairness towards our workers and we will
protect them from unfair competition one
way for doing so is a border Carbon
border adjustment mechanism frankly I
prefer to encourage our trading partners
to work with us for global level playing
field for the benefit of all of us
California for example is showing the
way with an emission trading system that
covers 85% of co2 emissions and I also
come in China for taking the first steps
towards a co2 pricing system and these
may be only first steps towards a level
playing field but if we achieve a global
pricing for co2 of our greenhouse gas
emissions if it turns into a global
trend we will have a global level
playing field where no carbon border tax
is needed anymore and this is an example
of a new modern international framework
we need this shows that if you engage
with Europe you will find a reliable
partner working for more sustained world
but we ask for fairness in return and we
have a lot to offer we are the largest
single market in the world we are one of
the three largest economies we are the
largest source and destination of
foreign direct investment we have more
than 80 free trade agreements
and over 700 international economic
agreements and the next negotiations
will start in February with our British
friends all these agreements are not
just about trade they are platforms to
shape and harness globalization and
their drivers to build common solutions
to challenges such as climate change or
digitalization we will be for sure
moving out of an economy based on fossil
fuels and we will be moving towards a
sustainable and a digital economy we're
working on this digital economy and we
consider of course data as a renewable
resource such as wind or Sun every 18
months we double the amount of data we
produce every 18 months these are
industrial data commercial data 85% of
which we never ever use and this is not
sustainable within such data they're
hidden treasures they're untapped
opportunities for business and for
society and therefore Europe is going to
co-create a framework to allow the use
of these data it should consist of a
trusted pool of non personalized data
that governments businesses and other
stakeholders can contribute to and
thereby we open up data as a resource
for innovation and bring new solutions
to the market and our scientists are
already beginning to do this we are
creating a European open science cloud
now it is a trusted space for
researchers to store their data
and to access data from researchers from
other disciplines we will create a pool
of information leading to a web of
research insight and every researcher
will be able to better use not only
their own data but also also those of
others they will thus come to new
insights they will have new findings new
solutions this is what we call the
European open science cloud and we are
the first in the world to do so it is
being developed in Europe for European
researchers for European solutions but
the idea is that once we have the rules
of the games of the game ready we will
open this up to a broader public sector
and to business as well so that
companies can come in share the data and
use the data and the idea is that we
will open it up to international
national players too in the very end we
have the biggest European science
organizations like the CERN or the MBL
the European molecular biology
laboratory major national centres
universities and many many others it is
from science for science but with a
clear perspective to open it up to a
broader society and economy enabling
sharing of non personal data will be one
important pillar of our new data
strategy the other pillar is the
protection of personal data ladies and
gentlemen for us the protection of a
person's digital dignity is the
overriding principle for us
the individual is not just a mere
customer or not just a data point among
others within the general data
protection regulation the GDP are we set
the standards for the world and we have
to set a similar frame for artificial
intelligence to a frame that allows
progress and allows research why are
protecting the personal privacy autonomy
and safety a frame that allows business
and digital solutions to grow in Europe
provided that they comply with it a
framework which will also give guidance
to international companies those who
want to do business in Europe ladies and
gentlemen this is about Europe shaping
its own future but to be more assertive
in the world we know we must step up in
some fields recent events have exposed
where we have to do more Libya shows the
cost of division hesitation I just come
from the conference on Libya in Berlin
last Sunday it was good to see that the
international community took an
important step in the right direction
and you can count on the European
Commission to strongly support the
process towards reconciliation and
reconstruction it takes very little
power to break a fragile balance but the
true power lies in putting the pieces
together back together again
during the last decade Europeans learned
the importance of a stable neighborhood
from Ukraine to the shores of the
Mediterranean
from the Western Balkans to the Sahel we
have learned the importance to invest
more in long-term stability and to
prevent crisis and this is where you can
make a real difference we are the
largest donor for development
cooperation cooperation in the world in
fact we invest in this more than the
rest of the world combined but we must
also do more when it comes to managing
crises as they develop and for that
Europe also needs credible military
capabilities and we have set up the
building blocks of a European defence
Union it is complementary to NATO and it
is different there is a European way to
foreign policy and foreign security
policy where hot power is an important
tool without any question but it is
never the only one heart power always
comes with diplomacy and conflict
prevention it always comes with
reconciliation and reconstruction which
is by the way something European
Europeans know very well because we all
have gone through this here in Europe
ladies and gentlemen while the world
around us is changing the things we want
from life remain the same we want to
take pride in our work we want to spend
time with our loved ones we want to
breathe clean air and to drink clean
water we want to feel at home where we
live we want to feel confident that our
children will have all these things we
take for granted and if we want to stay
true to all we hold dear we need to be
open-minded we need to embrace change we
have the collective responsibility to
find new ways to make this possible we
need to rediscover the power of
cooperation based on fairness based on
mutual respect and this is what I call
geopolitics of mutual interests this is
what Europe stands for this is what
Europe will work for and with all those
who are ready to join thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
Madam President
listening to us in European I'm proud
because you give back a kind of not a
kind of strong feeling of let's do it
and let's not just complain that we are
lagging behind us we have C capability
not only to do it but to lead it I think
that was the essence of your message now
if I'm I don't want to sound critical
now and to put some let's say salt into
the water
Europe was built on the notion of unity
in diversity and today we sometimes have
the feeling it's more diversity in unity
so my question is how do you ensure such
a political unity and cooperation across
European Member States will exist to
really successfully implement your
priorities like so green teal
competitiveness Digital Agenda and of
course what you said at the end see
geopolitical commission if I may say so
yeah yes this is this is the challenge
and this is the beauty of the European
Union because if you briefly look at the
history when I was born and went to
school there were only six member states
today just one lifespan later we have 28
member states and of course this is
always a challenge between the national
interests and the common European
interest we have to define and relating
to your question the good part at the
moment being is of course we had times
of hesitation we are times of division
but we all now feel the urge of having
to move forward not only in the field of
the European Green Deal but also in
digitalization
also in the topic of migration for
example the good part is I've put
forward my political guidelines but
there's also since summer the so called
strategic agenda of the European Council
this is all heads of state of God and
government of the Member States and its
strongly overlapping so in other words
the the political chambers have the
absolute same agenda on top comes the
European Parliament with a very strong
push towards this agenda too but there
is one more point where that is more
convincing it's the European people the
European people have understood that we
have to step forward what climate change
is concerned the European people have
understood that in digitalization we
have to put our own European Way forward
and I think it's very important for
politics and policies never to over see
if the people move forward that we adapt
our policies and are delivering what
they are asking for therefore we are in
a fortunate situation that all these
different entities of the European Union
come together with one very strong call
to be the first climate neutral
continent in 2050 to step forward in
digitalization as I pointed out and I
think this is a very good precondition
to really be active active and to move
forward I think when you have the right
strategy really having been a teacher
for strategic management when you have
to have when you have see convincing
strategy people will flow but you have
won attic additional obstacle because
until the end of CC R sub X it is
catching and maybe even beyond sis your
soup Rexy discussion will absorb a lot
of energy of
are you do you see successful slowdown
particularly is a critical first phase
the ability of implementation of your
ideas clear answers no and I'll explain
why first of all we have been dealing
with the phenomenon brexit already since
three and a half years now we have a
task force you will know Michel Barnier
he's heading the task force so this will
be the ongoing task force for the
negotiations with our British friends
and this is separated from the daily
business we were just talking about we
have to fulfill in the commission there
three more points I want to mention
first of all we do have now the
withdrawal agreement which has gone
through the European Parliament and the
British Parliament and within the
withdrawal a dream agreement we've
solved the largest the biggest problem
we had ahead of us the one is citizens
rights it was very important for us to
have clarity on citizens rights we have
3.5 million European citizens living in
the UK and vice-versa 1.2 million
British citizens living in the European
Union is good for them they have their
rights secured second piece on the
island of Ireland was of utmost
importance for us we wanted and we did
protect our member state Ireland and
this is successful done with the
withdrawal agreement and the third point
in the withdrawal agreement is the
financial settlement we're fine with
that tool we have on top the so-called
political declaration which is kind of a
chapeau that is describing the roadmap
we want to go on together and therefore
I just described that things are very
well set for the negotiations now we
will work day and night
to get that done there's one last point
we have to be very clear on there is a
difference whether you are a member
state or you're not a member state what
access to the single market is concerned
so the closer the United Kingdom is to
the European Union the better the access
to the single market if it's the UK's
choice not to do so to be more distant
to the European Union well then there
will be more distance of course to the
single market what level playing field
is concerned and what free movement of
goods capital and services is concerned
when resident
see people here in the halls business
people say are very affected positively
if you succeed what would be your
message to somehow can they help you to
to make happen well what you have in
mind for you yeah thank you for giving
me this opportunity
the first message is we are friends I
mean I pay tribute to 45 years of
contribution of our British friends to
the European Union all these civil
servants who shaped this European Union
- we are friends we share so many of
common values and common interests if
you look at the rest of the globe well
we know that we're sitting on the same
side of the table and we have a lot in
common
now we have to sort out this very clear
thing the what I just said
access to the single market there is a
condition either you align and you
accept the rules then you're closed or
you are more distant this is the UK's
choice so you can shape this choice -
but the overarching message is we are
friends we have been friends and we will
be friends because we have so much in
common to defend so let's conclude this
session by saying let's work together to
make you wish in happening
thank you so much
[Applause]